so there was a new article I think it
was published in nature I'll try to find
the link for it it's Bodhi year-old that
was based on high-resolution imaging of
neuronal connections and it's actually
reviewed in Kurt's Al's
Kurt's Wells book how to build a mind I
think that's the name of it and so it
turns out that the cortex is made out of
these columnar structures that are
pre-organized units of neurons and
they're replicated across the entire
cortex it's basically the same structure
and like the older let's say
connectionist idea was that neurons that
fire together wire together right that
that's happen of course that's pretty
standard neurology but the the columns
are already pre-wired so it's actually
columns that fire together that wired
together but there's but there's even
more with the high-resolution scanning
so it turns out that underneath the
columnar structure there are these
pre-built highways that are connected
connective tissue that are pre
pre-prepared so the columns have the
option to connect to the to the
underlying highway and then that highway
can connect other columns so it's as if
in implicit in the brain organization
and this is at the cortical level say
nothing of subcortical organization
there's already preexistent likelihoods
that certain neurons will fire will wire
together yeah so and and what else is
cool is that this is actually
architectural II quite regular so they
found that the these super highways are
arranged in lines and and and in at
right angles to one another so it's
almost like a three-dimensional
structure of wired cubes that underlies
the neuronal structure so that's some
neurological evidence for the archetypal
idea